MSNBC interviewed Pittsburgh area Trump
voters in the lead up to the imminent
election about January 6th and I'm going
to play some of this for you and what
you are going to see demonstrated in
this clip
is how effective Republican
disinformation has been the stuff that
they repeat January 6th was antifa the
woman who was shot Ashley Babbitt was a
hero all of these things that you and I
go there's no evidence for this who
could possibly believe this crap
here are the people who believe this
crap and the most important message I
have for you about it is
the MSNBC didn't go and have to look in
little crevices to find folks with these
beliefs this is a disturbingly
representative sample of I would
estimate somewhere between one-fifth and
one-third of the voting public this is
scary dystopian stuff look at this and
look at how weaponized their beliefs are
Doug mastriano was at the Insurrection
and he was photographed breaching one of
the restricted areas
is that okay which area because I saw a
video where Capital officers was taking
away barriers and unlocking doors so
that's the talking point there was no
trespassing the officers let everybody
in
I mean I I opened the gate so it
shouldn't be disqualifying for an
elected official
participated in January 6. he didn't
strike anybody he didn't hurt anybody
and the only one that died was a
protester there not a capital police
that's the only one that died that's the
only one who died a police officer
remember unarmed female veteran died
this is the whole thing where she she
was a hero she was there protesting
peacefully in Bubba I did die no that
was a stroke that's not that's not on
site by that that's because he shouldn't
have been a police officer so what do
you make though support the police right
the guy who died of a heart attack he
just never had any business being in law
enforcement we backed the blue overall
of January 6th I mean it was watching
that footage it was pretty disturbing I
mean there were people throwing
excrement at the walls and it was our
you know it's the capital it almost a
lot like antifa's action except on a
much smaller scale will look the same as
the black lives matter right that's what
I saw the similarities
One Burns Kenosha but so it's okay just
because just because one side that you
disagree with I'm saying infiltrated
antifa infiltrated Now understand if
you're listening this is a group of all
white people
it's relevant only in so far as when we
think about
what is the group most susceptible in a
sense to this type of misinformation it
does seem overwhelmingly to be uh right
wing
White
mostly male but lately increasingly
female voters and that is exactly what
we have here for the other anybody I
don't see arms anybody anybody who
caused property destruction that needs
to be dealt with yeah if you're there
making your voice heard at the people's
house no less yeah that's again it's a
fundamental constitutional right of an
American citizen and people should not
be being held political prisoner so this
is the talking point of the rioters are
being held as political prisoners which
Marjorie Taylor green uses I mean you
could spoon feed anything to these folks
and they would buy it uh because of it
for misdemeanors that's East Germany
that's Easter tactics yeah that's what's
scary
it was an actual fiery but mostly
peaceful protest
and the other ones that were the other
was the protest
legitimate in your eyes I feel like is
using it as their rice dog fire oh my
God that's exactly what they're using it
as
oh my God this is really really scary
stuff really scary stuff let's let's
skip ahead and listen to a little bit
more after
people were still there and stuff yeah
but it's but it started while he was
still speaking and and they talk about
the fact that oh he didn't do anything
for this amount of time it's like well
he was giving his speech and right so
this is the argument that Trump couldn't
have stopped what was happening because
he was still speaking when it was
happening that's not true we all were
there live the breach happened well well
after Trump was long gone the the timing
just is a lie
now again that's also a lie Trump has
insisted I requested ten thousand troops
in Nancy Pelosi denied it there is no
evidence that Nancy Pelosi denied
anything but more importantly there's no
evidence Trump requested any such troops
there is simply no evidence Trump says
it
no evidence of it they believe it's not
just some of the lies they believe every
lie yeah well it actually isn't in
Pelosi's power too
she's bigger the house she's no
authority over that whatsoever and
frankly I think that's a good thing but
well then but even so isn't she in
charge of security if there was afraid
of a risk that she was offered them then
why didn't she uh
preemptively beef up Capital police
right but she does have this the
authority to do these are very serious
brain worms and I know well with the
pejorative there is something really
wrong here there is something very wrong
where every lie they believe and the
most important question for us is
it's very clear that just putting up
good candidates who tell the truth
and who actually care about constituents
it is not enough so what has to happen
what has to happen I don't know the
answer
and that's maybe the scariest part of
all of it we'll have these clips on our
Instagram find us on Instagram at
davidpackman show
something in your home that you use
every day contributes to deforestation
and climate change and that's toilet
paper in the U.S alone over 30 million
trees each year are required to meet
toilet paper demands contributing to
deforestation soil erosion devastating
loss of biodiversity our sponsor real
paper makes sustainable toilet paper
that is 100 made from bamboo a bamboo
stock keeps growing it can be harvested
forever it means that the soil and the
ecosystem aren't disrupted no carbon
removing trees are cut down the paper
industry has a massive effect on
deforestation and climate change but you
alone using bamboo toilet paper can make
a positive impact because for the toilet
paper that just one American uses in
their lifetime hundreds of trees are
required put an end to that right now
with real paper the best part is the
stuff is really great it's just normal
Soft toilet paper real paper loves the
David Pacman show they're giving my
audience 30 off your first order and
free shipping when you go to
realpaper.com Pacman and use the code
Pacman at checkout the link is down
below